[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
JOSH SOLT: My name is Josh
Solt. I am partner development
manager at Google Play.
And I manage kids
apps and games.
So today, I'll be
talking about optimizing
for a post-install world.
Namely, how do you
retain and engage
families in your ecosystem?
So you've spent a
lot of time, effort,
resources getting a user to
ultimately download your app,
right?
It's quite the process.
There's motivation, discovery,
expectation, search, filter,
and then finally the download.
So what about
after the download?
So let's look at
the user funnel.
We've got the view listing,
install, open the app.
Today, I really want to focus
on the bottom two-- engaging
with your app and retention.
I have a number of
different case studies.
Partners have been
willing to share with us,
and hopefully some great
facts and data that you'll
find interesting
for your businesses.
So since acquisition
costs are high,
it's really important to
engage your most loyal users.
Optimizing the lifetime
value of your traffic
is key for acquisition
campaigns and making it most
cost effective.
So this is a pretty
staggering stat.
50% to 90% of app users have
churned after just 30 days.
So just let that
sink in for a moment.
No matter how great your app
is, that's just how it is.
And that's really the struggle
that a lot of developers
find and lays the
groundwork for what we're
going to talk about today.
So what are some of the
key reasons for churn?
First of all, there's
poor technical quality.
Another one is inefficient
or unclear value proposition.
Thirdly, outdated
content or functionality.
Not personalized, and also
too many push notifications.
All of these can cause major
headaches for your business.
And we're going to
address them today.
So the format of
this presentation
is really threefold.
I'm going to start off by
talking about user onboarding.
We actually just had a great
presentation from 01 Digital.
They talked about how they're
thinking through onboarding.
And we have some great data
from Budge Studios as well.
Second of all, we're going
to talk about successfully
releasing new
features and content,
how PBS kids is thinking through
that, and other partners.
And then finally, we're going
to talk about reengaging users.
So to start off, how to
make user onboarding great.
And thank you, again,
for your presentation.
So now that you've had a
user download your title,
it's time to make sure
they keep using it.
And thinking through your
tutorial and registration
is key.
On the tutorial side,
focus on the value
and make it fun and simple.
Also allow users
to skip the demo
and see it later as an option.
And be sure to explain
ancillary features
and make sure it's
relevant to the user
and focus on your top metric.
And then-- this will be a
common theme through today
is just really testing,
testing, testing, and iterate
for your best D1
and D7 retention.
On the registration
side, be sure that you
show value for the
information asked.
So what does the user get?
And don't bar access.
And optimize your onboarding
value proposition.
So you really have to focus
on getting your user to engage
with your app in an instant.
It's a very competitive
world out there, as we know.
We were just talking about
how much competition there
is in the market,
so you really have
to differentiate
yourself that way.
So familiarize new
users with your app
by designing a simple and
easy onboarding process.
Make it fast and seamless,
contextual, and part
of the product experience.
Also, ask for minimal input,
while gathering the information
you need to create engagement.
So one great example is a
developer out of Montreal,
Canada called Budge Studios.
Budge Studios has
created their own IP
and they're also licensing
such prominent IP
as Hello Kitty and Caillou,
as well as Thomas the Train.
So a few of the things
that Budge Studios thinks
through-- one is
fast time to fun.
Really, how do you get
someone into the app quickly?
How do you get them
having fun right away?
The first playable moment
is really critical here.
An early win to build a
user's confidence is key.
We'll touch about
this later as well.
So be sure to cut
the unnecessary steps
to your process.
And for effective
onboarding, you also
need a check for dropoffs.
So in terms of
Budge Studios, they
want to get players in the game
faster and be wary of drop off.
And really, one
key metric here is
to find the right value for
first time user experience.
And this actually was
not the case originally
with Miss Hollywood.
They found that
it was too hard--
this title-- for preschoolers.
So by making the first
time experience easier,
they actually increased their
first time retention by 11%.
That 11% actually
accounts for millions
of additional minutes of play.
And test, test, test.
Like we were saying,
you've got to keep testing.
Budge Studios, through
their rigorous testing,
was able to find that an
initial game loop included
five characters,
one of which had
issues with their
microphone permissions.
So after adjusting this
permission and fixing it,
they saw an increase to 74% of
first time users in this loop,
compared to 25% in
the previous loop.
And we had the honor of having
Play Kids present here earlier
today.
They're another great
example, in terms
of focusing on user onboarding.
And they've spent a lot
of time running tests
to update their onboarding
value proposition.
So here you have the
old onboarding, and then
the new one that
they rolled out.
The new version actually took
their conversion rate from 0.4%
all the way up to above 0.7%.
And this pop up that you
see, which really laid out
their value proposition in
a more clear fashion, that
increased their sales by 81%.
So 81% increase in sales by
just improving your pop up
is a pretty staggering number.
So in terms of onboarding, you
can test using onboarding flows
with Firebase remote config.
You can run A/B
tests experiments
or change app behavior,
control custom key value pairs
from the console, and make
changes that are instant.
Another key factor that not
everyone is really taking
advantage of are avatars.
I love this quote
from Play Science.
It says, "When children were
asked to design their own app,
the feature that they
listed as the most important
was the ability to
create their own avatar.
Yet few at the top playful
games offer this unique feature,
suggesting a great
opportunity for developers."
And here, I'd like
to point to Roblox,
another prominent
developer based in the US.
They have been really
focused on their avatar.
And as soon as a user
interacts with their app,
they give them control
to customize it.
So what have been the results?
Well, this is pretty
staggering once again.
60% of new sign ups
customize their avatar.
And out of that
60%, they're seeing
that the retention rate is
1.8 times better-- almost
2x the other user group.
Next, I would like to talk
about how to engage and retain
families through successfully
releasing new features
and content.
Once again, Roblox is
a great example here.
They have a systematic
release methodology.
They test it with beta
users, so making sure
that you're really
getting out there,
testing it with the right
user community that's
appropriate for
your ages, right?
Making sure it's technically
stable, show what's new.
And lastly, analyze
that performance.
PBS Kids is really
a great example
of a developer out there who's
refreshing content and updating
it on a regular basis.
They add new games weekly.
They have seasonal updates
around big moments-- Halloween,
Christmas.
Here it can be Day of Kids,
a number of other moments.
And be sure to
update around that.
update your icons.
We saw some of the results
that Play Kids had in terms
of updating their icons.
And that's low hanging fruit.
If you can improve your
conversion rate 78%,
like they are saying,
that's pretty tremendous
and not a tremendous
amount of work.
So the key question is, is
there enough value in your app?
I wanted to point to this
example of Budge Studios.
This is a graph that
showed retention.
The top number is when they
gave away three free items,
and the bottom is when
they gave away two.
So as you can see, that
really spiked their numbers.
This isn't necessarily what
a lot of developers think.
There is usually the
perception that you
have to limit a lot
of the free content,
but we're actually
finding otherwise.
And this is some great
data from Budge Studios,
that the first time
experience was better
and that actually led to
greater retention, engagement,
and ultimately revenue
by actually giving away
that third character.
And the third part
I'd like to talk about
is reengaging users and
leveraging your key channels.
So be sure to ensure that all
your organic channels are being
clearly marketed using Android
and update your existing
channels, including e-mail,
website, social, and YouTube.
Here, we have some
examples from Roblox.
They have an inbox in their app.
And so they're able to
push notifications directly
to the user.
Some other examples
include what they're doing
on social media and YouTube.
A lot of developers
aren't really leveraging
the About page on
their YouTube page,
so that About page
is a great place
to link to your
Google Play listing.
You can also link to your
website, social media accounts.
It's easy.
And we've seen some strong
results out of that.
Roblox is also using social
media, as I mentioned before.
Form a Facebook,
Twitter, and they're also
doing YouTube cards.
YouTube cards can pop up
on the side of your videos
if you're running different
videos on YouTube.
Those are free to use
and another great way
to reengage users, bring them
back to your store listing
page on Google Play.
Toca Boca also provides
a great example
of how a top premium developer
is leveraging their ecosystem
to really push new titles out.
And a great example of that
is their Toca Life series.
They have a number of
different Toca Life apps,
including Toca Life
Town, Toca Life Vacation,
and they actually just
released Toca Life Farm,
which is one of our
top premium titles
currently on Google Play.
So Toca Life is a series of
apps that gives kids access
to a role playing universe
filled with everyday fun.
It's uniquely created for
kids and it was really
a direct result of communicating
with their fan base
and taking user feedback.
So since the release of
the first app in May 2014,
Toca Boca has received more
than 60,000 feature requests
and reviews from kids
all over the world.
And it's feedback that has
informed their Toca Life series
and has brought us these titles.
And this title,
Toca Life Vacation,
was their most
successful launch ever.
And it's really
because they leveraged
their previous ecosystem.
So 32% of users downloading
Toca Life Vacation
had downloaded all of
the previous three apps.
And 38% of users downloading
Toca Life Vacation
had downloaded one or two
of those previous apps.
So be sure that your
cross-promotion is really
on point.
Once again, text and
make sure that it's
relevant in driving the
benefits that you're going for.
Another one is using
rich notifications
to bring users back to your app.
So a few best practice here here
is include actionable content,
deep linking to the
right part of your app,
stacking similar notifications,
and avoid spamming,
and testing.
So what are the things
to do with notifications?
Well, one, get users familiar.
Two, consider re-activation.
Three, try to make an
emotional connection.
Four, include
actionable content.
Five, deep link.
And six, really
consider your audience.
This is especially important
in the kids and family space.
And then just four
things that you
want to avoid and not do
with notifications are
don't push spam notifications.
Don't forget to
expire notifications.
Don't push ads.
House ads are permitted, though.
And don't leave notifications
up to guesswork.
So the case study
here that I wanted
to highlight on the
notification and messaging side
is SpeakaBoos.
They utilize a combination of
notifications, emails, push,
and social media to
reinforce a message that
furthers their brand.
For SpeakaBoos,
each touchpoint is
designed to motivate a love of
reading by connecting children
to their interests.
So SpeakaBoos' push
notification, this example,
it's fun.
It's relevant.
They said, did you know
it's world pasta day?
So that really activated
their user base.
They also time it with
new content releases,
exclusive content, holiday
events, and discounts.
And they've seen strong results
from their push notifications,
as well as from their messaging.
They regularly test A/B
results, analyze those metrics,
and optimize based on
a variety of factors.
And this has resulted
in a nice uplift.
So news story day
for SpeakaBoos is
an e-mail that promotes a
special and exclusive content.
That has driven a 5%
increase in click rates.
And content that makes use
of appropriate hashtags
is another key to this.
Overall, they've seen a 60%
increase with web traffic
when it's paired
with social accounts
for 5% of monthly traffic.
So I hope that was helpful.
I know we covered
a lot of things,
wanted to include a lot
of case studies and data
from some of our top partners.
Hopefully, in the
next presentation,
next time we come
down here, we'll
include more data from
a lot of you guys.
We know this is collaborative,
but just to reiterate,
the three key things
that we really
encourage you to
think through are
onboarding, new features
and content releases,
and reengaging your users.
So thank you very much.